are the safest spaces for all races
maggot places
we all want to live in a utopia which is
defined as an ideal place
social perfection the woke wants this
badly or so they claim
but what if that utopia already existed
and it's maga country or mega country i
would say maga
i don't know why john nolte it sounds
more cultural
we're going to maga country john nolte
writes in breitbart that life in rural
america where republican trump voters
live and govern is clean
safe and racially tolerant while the big
cities led mostly by democrats have high
crime gun violence
and poverty rates nolte describes his
personal experience
living in the red state of north
carolina where people of different races
get along
reports of hate crimes there are fewer
than in liberal cities like portland and
san francisco
and if you get hit by fireworks in the
country it's probably an accident
the u.s cities with the most murders
last year are not run by republicans
and big city homicides were up in the
first three months of this year too
chicago 864 people have been shot this
year almost all of them people of color
12 people were shot this tuesday alone
maybe they just haven't defunded police
enough yet
last year people moved out of the big
cities in droves often
fleeing the effects of policies that
they voted for
so i hope they find utopia and when they
get there they don't vote
all right dr prager do you buy this i do
buy it
and it's it's it's the worst there's
something worse than that
i feel like the downer of the show
tonight it's
not my temperament joe cat has stuff for
that
and that is that then these people
after voting in horrible policies that
destroyed their cities
moved to nice places yes and then ruined
those places
californians moved and ruined washington
oregon and arizona new yorkers are
ruining
florida it's uh it's uh
it's it's eerie the whole thing i was
gonna say new yorkers moved it moved to
new jersey and ruined it but
that's hard too late what i love
new jersey some of the best highways
out of new jersey i've ever seen i don't
know why why am i making fun of new
jersey i love you
you know uh uh julie there is a point to
what dr prager saying
is that you know what if you shouldn't
you sign a contract when you move to
a red state that you're not allowed to
vote for five years
oh yeah i i mean i suppose i get your
point on new yorkers going to florida
and screwing that up but we already
mucked up new york city so i think that
they should put up a wall
outside of new york city and build the
wall and keep them here
and kick out the governor and mayor
while you're at it but i mean our the
crime in new york city is out of control
have you been walking around and how
weird it's getting it's very weird
and i thought it was starting to get
back but we new yorkers have to be
very vigilant like for example today i
got my first vaccine right here
and i had two options either get sleepy
and a little like
woozy before this show or get it in the
bronx tomorrow
yeah i went with this guy like do i want
to get shot in the bronx or do i want a
shot in the arm in midtown
so i'm a little whoo-hoo that's okay
that's okay
you shouldn't be getting your injections
on the street though julie that is
it was free i know the health plan here
isn't the best but you know
i don't know cat uh um
is this enough like let's say you're a
woke liberal and you're tired of the
policies
can you live in the rural states are you
gonna miss all the
art galleries and the art galleries
well we used to have those in new york
yes right the the good thing about
living in a city is that there was
you know that you could go to see this
concert you could go see a play or you
could go to a bar and then another bar
then another bar and then another bar
etc some people would do uh and now in
new york it's just like all the bad
stuff
but you can't do anything and you're
just sitting there at your apartment
that you're paying way too much for and
you want
why are you doing and it sucks we found
a syringe cap
in my dog's poop the other day oh sorry
about that yeah
thanks a lot never letting you near him
again
but there's no reason to do it but i
think that people would want to move
and then maybe just say you know because
they have these
this inflated sense of importance that
they're going to move to these places
and oh i saw this and i'm going to do
this and i'm going to change things
because they don't even realize that
they're ruining the places i don't think
they realize it dr sheriff how long you
been in the united states
15 years 15 years so have you noticed
okay you live in new york have you
noticed
uh a dramatic change in the city i i am
very
like i want to get the hell out of here
but my wife wants to stay because she
grew up
in cities and in i try to convince her
you know so what i've done is i've uh
raised an entirely different
family so i could live both worlds
i don't know what i'm saying at this
point dr cerf i mean i feel like i'm the
donor of the show as well
in fact but here's the thing so so i'm
not surprised by this
where there's more racism more pollution
more crime is where there's more people
that's not surprising
so i think that this is what we're
learning here and i think this is like a
classical case of coalition and
causation
more crime more police if you have no
police there's gonna be no crime no
it's the point that uh we're seeing an
effect
where there's just more people moving to
cities across the world and especially
in the us
and with that we're going to see a lot
more things if you're a poor guy and you
want to
beg for money you want to go to a city
where you can actually get it that is
true yeah
that is true you don't want to it's hard
to do that on that dirt road for a long
time
yes yes one car every four hours
spare change at that point you probably
just start carjacking
yeah that is true yeah that's your
solution for everything you don't know
fewer people would see you
not that i'm not that you should i can't
believe you're endorsing carjacking on a
box
all right